days after withdrawing the Ukraine grain
deal Russia says All Ships Bound for
Ukraine in the Black Sea are now
potential military targets and that has
sent wheat prices soaring but it's
unclear what specific action Moscow will
take if a ship passes through the U.S
though has warned that civilian ships
may be targeted Russia's President
Vladimir Putin has now laid down
conditions for returning to the
agreement
the first demand for re-entry to the
grain deal is the withdraw of sanctions
on supplies of Russian grain and
fertilizers second all obstacles for
Russian Banks and financial institutions
servicing food and fertilizer supplies
must be removed we are talking about
their immediate connection to the Swift
International banking settlement system
we do not need any promises we need
these conditions to be met
the U.N and Turkish mediator deal
brought relief to countries around the
world especially developing countries
the United Nations the EU and the US
have all warned about the impact on
Global Food security after Russia's
withdrawal
Russia continues to use food as a weapon
of War this is the second day in a row
we've seen the Russian Federation make
threats against ships in international
water a second day in a row after
launching attacks on Odessa which is the
major port for shipping Ukrainian grain
so I think it ought to be quite clear to
everyone in the world right now that
Russia is using food as a weapon of War
not just against the Ukrainian people
but against all the people in the world
especially the most underdeveloped
countries who depend on grain for them
from the region
meanwhile Russia has continued its
attacks on the Ukrainian port city of
Odessa for a second night Kiev says that
a grain and oil terminal were hit but
Russia says it successfully hit military
facilities and ammunition Depots from
Moscow here's Julia shopovalova with the
reaction from the Russian military
we can see how Russia's termination of
the grain deal has resulted in some
serious consequences as the defense
Ministry has issued a statement
addressing all International ships
heading towards the Ukrainian ports at
midnight July the 20th all ships sailing
in the Black Sea and approaching the
Ukrainian ports will be considered
carriers of military cargo involved in
the Ukrainian conflict on the Kiev side
the Russian military named several
Maritime areas in the Northwestern and
South Eastern parts of the international
waters of the Black Sea which have been
declared temporarily dangerous for
navigation with pulling out of the grain
deal Russia meant it wouldn't allow
Ukraine to export grain from its ports
and provide its trips with safe Passage
through the Black Sea to Turkey plus
earlier the Kremlin announced that the
grain deal had been a cover for Ukraine
to deliver weapons into the country
while Ukraine called on turkey and the
U.N to continue transportations of its
grain so the Russian side now predicts
that it's hardly possible that Ukrainian
Merchant ships will be escorted by
warships of other countries so the
defense ministry's decision May kill a
significant part of Ukraine's foreign
trade reporting from Moscow Julia Al
Jazeera
let's take a closer look at the green
deal signed in June of last year Ukraine
and Russia had agreed that ships would
be able to depart from three key
Ukrainian ports on the Black Sea
including Odessa Turkish Ukrainian and
un staff monitored the loading of grain
to ensure that ships weren't carrying
any weapons the UN says the deal allowed
it to transport more than 725
000 tons of wheat to help people in need
in countries hit by War and extreme
weather events
Patrick butry is a defense and security
Analyst at the University of bath he
believes Russia's suspicion that cargo
ships are being used to supply weapons
is unfounded
I think you know on the face of it a
threat like that is escalatory uh but
it's aimed at a certain maximum leverage
and it has had an impact and a Major
Impact but it's not something that's
come completely out of the blue
um in terms of the sort of the security
risk essentially I don't see and again
I'm not like a naval Insurance expert
here but it once there's a threat to
shipping
um someone needs to guarantee uh the the
either the the indemnity or the safety
of the vessel uh Ukraine will try to do
that I think they've already set up a
fund and that's been existing for a
while to to try to entice
um shipping companies in any way but I
would say with the with the threat that
Russia has now made the most likely
outcome here is at least in the short
term it will kill the deal which was
already being strangled anyway it's the
interesting thing the way that that has
been working is essentially boats are
coming out of three different Ukrainian
ports and they're helped by Ukrainian
Pilots to navigate the minefields in the
sea basically laid by both the Russians
and the ukrainians then they get out to
A muster point and then
um and then um sail to towards the
Bosphorus and this is all coordinated
with the UN and and turkey and Russia
and Ukraine as observers and they can
check the votes as they go through so
the accusation that Ukraine will be
bringing in military hardware on this is
dubious I would say because the Russians
have had the chance to inspect them if
they wanted to so
um uh that that seems to be be a You
Know spoken smoke and mirrors as usual